the Red Wings in their home red and valeno on
the draw out there with fabry and Raymond who
drives the goal fabri a shot and that'll
be held by Ilia samsonov Mickey Redmond
your turn to speak to Brink and Dylan Lin and
on comes David Pon after Raymond started the
game so a little juggling early here for the Red
Wings here's Mor cider with a shot over there to
help break that up was neander again up there
along with Taris in front for Tyler berzi and
the former Redwing in that familiar 59 Maple's
penalty killing 27th at just 72% in the last
five games they've been under 65% there's a save
by Samson off off a quick shot out with it comes
Noah Gregor he's got good speed the former San
Jose Shark took a shot and lion with the save
on the short side hopefully before the end of the
night here's Mata the mule yeah for the playoff he
had no oh came right to the blue and that'll be
held backto back hattricks in 08 that champ face
off how important are they [__] control and
Ma goes right down below and bodies everywhere
net comes off Baleno shoved in wow that's a good
stop by samsonov watch Matthews opening the right
side neander mirrored there by cofin turns away
and gets it in down low again for tar there's
Matthews good save by Li coming out on that one
under five to go here in the opening period at
a vich arena in Stockholm go spar with a good
move but then lost it came loose in front big
save there on the backand from maxy looking for
his first go Matthews had one pretty good here
earlier in the period but a bit of a miscue by
Detroit little miscommunication defensively they
had a lot of that in the first period last
night not so tonight's been physical again
tonight cider mixing it up with Max doy giving
it to him again KN with a good move circling
back but look at this move that he makes coming
to the front how do you even think of this stuff
holy smoke he's young wow second round pick
in 21 there you see the cross check William
neander though as you mentioned in our open Mick
in Oldtown Stockholm is that William neander an
unrestricted free agent after the season here's
Tyler bzi with a high shot shrug to sze by Alex
lion we have
[Applause]
seen and the net is off and down and hurt
wman Kendrick Nicholson Here's another look
at it wman got checked it looked like
he he blew the tire yeah he uh watches
steps right there yeah oh yeah he went he went
Dangerously in there where he couldn't protect
himself yeah his head did catch the bar and had
Samson off ducking strong steals back to Ras oh
what a stop loose in the blue is it covered up
by Toronto Daniel strong is a shooter it'll be
interesting to see if he lets her go he's
got a rocket so in a goal this game seven
to go in the second first career penalty
shot for spraw and it's a goal Daniel wow
Red Wings lead it one in a p did he ever put
the yo-yo to sleep on that one it's a delayed
geak I don't think I don't think they need
to start an investigation on this one with
the linesman certainly got his two cents
worth over there oh what a move by sprong
hor Larkin back for de Brink de Bret played it
into the corner Riley ahead intercepted though
cider big save there by samsonoff here's
Lucas Raymond Raymond circles up high he
finds cider it goes off to Brink it down low
Raymond oh what a shot Lucas Raymond has done
it again and the Red Wings lead it two to
nothing but time for Raymond to assess the
situation what a what a rocket that was
and look at the reaction of Lucas Raymond
when he realizes it's in under the left
that same corner he scored on last night wow
davaris across the line for Tuesday drives the
net Taris turns back able to find mccab he's
checked by cop shot came through Taris into
the middle good play in tight there by nander
neander Waits neander right in they score berzi
right there nice turn by 88 and you go to
the front look at for he going to the front
of the net stick I mean really firmly placed
right next to his skate a NE Anders looking
he sees it Morgan Riley played it up good
move here by Gregor playback slot shot oh
and that's off the post and out off the crossbar
and up into the netting on a broken play Camp no
luck at all through the National Hockey League
tavarus back for nander saved by lion rebound
it's loose oh he made a couple give and go
this Tavaris Line's been the best line for
Toronto tonight there's the first save pretty
easy there got a save on berzi another one on
berzi and four red jerseys actually five you can
throw a blanket over them trying to help cover
up out of Matthews reach marner's got it Mitch
Marner pulls back another smooth move a great
save by lion pretty good stop and goal by Mitch
Marner he fiddles around with a 100 Point number
every season that's their best shift Marner and
Matthews in company tonight as Jake wman had to
exit the game in the second period injured oh
good save oh and another stop off the rebound
off Matthews I the first save was a good one
on a redirect and then Matthews got his own
rebound right there o what an acrobatic
save mainlander with four shots now and
he's set up a goal he's got it again
that one was blocked terat ties up
tovaris Mitch Marner to the middle neander
scores He is unbelievable his 11th goal his
24th Point all in 16 consecutive
games it's a tie game [Applause]
clean and tar with the draw and Toronto control
to Marner neander who's played a lot of Center
they tinkered with naner at Center on the wing
though for Taris took that draw though Hall gets
bumped for's got it fori looks at front
they score fory to tamarus it's three to
two neander himself went back and CAU it and then
it was behind the net for Tu he causes all kinds
of trouble with h and a perfect setup to tavarus
who has had himself quite a game oh boy and Taris
had been kicked out of the faceof circle knocked
down in front and cleared and that's going to do
it the Toronto Maple Lees with three in the
third period come back to win it three to two